I'd like to give a uh congratulations to
Mr Ray EPS on avoiding jail time despite
privately saying he orchestrated January
6 and being seen on camera numerous
times advocating people enter the
building which is of course inciting an
Insurrection by Democrat standards and
then of course I'd like to give an
honorable mention to Enrique tario for
beating the record of uh Ray apps by
getting 20 plus years in prison despite
not even being in DC so of course the
internet is r with individuals accusing
rays of being a Fed because because it
makes quite no sense that of all the
people that have been charged some 1,700
many of them have rece have received
jail time and some of them did literally
nothing like walking around Ray EPS
actually was at the front line where
they breached the barricade he was
telling people to enter the capital
premeditated and he admitted on camera
he knew that doing so was a crime he
would be arrested for he gets no jail
time no travel restrictions a $500 fine
$100 community service oh boy